and now it's time for our overlooked
nostalgic DVD of the week and having
just come off of rise of the Guardians
um it strangely reminded me of another
film that I had kind of forgotten about
um so it's nostalgic in that sense it's
not that old but it's forgotten and my
pick of the week is bolt well obviously
that would tie in to Santa Claus and the
Easter Bunny absolutely absolutely I
would love to hear you explain that I'm
gonna tell you why wiseass oh my ass is
wise don't have the wiseness of my ass
it's the only part of you with his why's
there dick he's on that and ask anyway
the I'm sorry that's okay
my dick is wise to review the movie are
you finished
yes okay similar setups with a main
character who's trying to find his place
in the world but it came more from the
animation it was another film that was
done in 3d at the time and the action
was very similar and the animation in
some sense is very similar what I mean
by that is both these films knew how to
capture motion which sounds silly its
animation honking not know how to
capture motion it's really easy not to
do to actually animate a film and get a
true sense of motion you're flying
through space you're on a rollercoaster
ride you're in a helicopter is very
difficult in both these films really
nailed it but on top of that the other
thing I really like is it's a good story
and like rise of the Guardians it's good
not great and I know that sounds like
I'm downplaying the movie but something
you have to keep in mind is much like I
well I think animated films are better
nowadays generally speaking but
occasionally get these sort of ruts and
Disney at that time now were they making
good movie with the exception of Pixar
but their CG Department was definitely
but the exceptions Pixar which then they
would dump then they went back and it
wasn't the process one day I think they
were getting rid of them yeah Marco this
was at a time when when what was the one
like home on the range I mean these were
the sort of films that were coming
and Meet the Robinsons exactly this sort
of film came out at a time when Disney
was not making good movies and it was a
solidly good movie it's not Toy Story 2
or 3 it's not a Miyazaki film but the
film stars John Travolta of all people
as a dog a trained dog who basically is
the co-star on a sort of teen kids spy
show a show that looks very similar what
Disney would air actually actually that
was one of the brilliant one of the
brilliant things about the film is you
know the people who made this movie had
watch the Disney Channel is like you
only should just totally kind of make
fun of these things so they created this
character penny and they created this
show that she's in and she forms a
relationship you know with the stunt dog
the only issue is the stunt dog doesn't
realize that he's in a TV show he's
taking all of this literally so it has
much like rise of the guardians borrowed
elements this has elements of I would
say like the three amigos where they're
not quite aware initially or galaxies
cause we have this this group of people
who's not aware of the joke so long
story short the dog gets separated and
after that has to find his way back well
he keeps thinking he has to go save
penny who is in no real danger because
she's just child actress and this is all
imaginary along the way on this road
trip movie he hooks up with a cat that's
been abandoned and then much like rise
the Guardians which is one of those
stories about faith and having faith in
people and faith in others you know it's
about bold trying to teach the cat you
know to have faith in people even though
she was abandoned and then I love
hearing you talks to see a bolt is
trying to teach the cat but there are
things happening in these movies that's
the problem people think kids films
can't have anything real going on that's
bullshit agree I agree shit no I totally
agree it's just living it here no I like
movies like this because they're trying
to tell a story this isn't freaking baby
geniuses these people put real work into
this and you shut up I like it's a good
movie it just sounds funny hearing you
talk so seriously about the cat learning
of this anyway the very end there's a
big role
mr. Chainz Miley Cyrus sings a song you
know I saw the trailer I got more
excited why I saw the trailer because I
did really like the concept for it
actually much much like rise of
guardians I've ever Z the sacrum a tree
I didn't American high school I really
liked the trailer and actually I think I
got my hopes a little higher than what
the film delivered because what I found
that the film was very sweet wasn't as
funny as I thought but here's the other
thing I think audiences are opening up
to this too that's not necessarily bad
film I can be very character yeah and
this head and why I film like
wreckit-ralph works wreckit-ralph is
actually not that funny of a movie when
you get down to it when other characters
in the world can Aladdin and Shrek and
you got a thousand jokes but really
recommend more character than both those
movies put together so I and I think
Travolta as as the dog actually was a
great choice and he did he was a very
genuine he was incredible he was
incredibly genuine whatever cyrus XYZ
was in that movie she was great i forgot
to play the cat do you remember I just
know she's from Kirby enthusiasm I
forgot she was excellent the shot
address the hamster in some parts of the
film do feel padded so that is the one
reason why I don't think this film got
as much recognition as it deserved
because becoming a road movie it does
kind of meander a bit but I think the
strong moments in it are really strong
it touches on three things you got
abandonment with the cat in the case of
the dog it brought up a very interesting
thing which is I've always wondered if
like stuck dogs and dogs in a film or
kind of messed up a bit because they're
always surrounded by eight billion
different peoples
jump do this and I wonder if the dogs
kinda like oh nothing I think that's the
saddest part to me in the whole movies
actually in the beginning when when
shooting is done but the dog is still
ready to pounce like he just wants to
make sure it is her when he's just at
the door and even when she wants to play
he looks like he does want to play but
no he has to protect yesterday and I
thought that was a very tragic dog
jaz'mon flex
yeah and that's always ready to add and
there's and it's something that I think
they touched upon in which is another
they're like all three of the characters
had something to and that's something
that you know she was somewhat
perfunctory to the storage is only their
beginning and then something left the
child actors character it was
we're deal when you look at how that
movie ends it's a rejection of the
Hollywood system and that these people
are just dancing monkeys here to perform
and that was the case with both one and
then she kind of feels bad you know
because my hormones can abuse yeah it's
a strangely dark um if you really want
to look at it that way um but you know
my it's got some great lines dude I
think my ferret is cuz he takes
everything so seriously that the cat
very much it's lifting from Toy Story
you know you are a stunt dog you know
what are you talking about these like
you know I I have to save her and the
cats it's like you're out of your mind
is is like of course you would think
that cuz I'm a dog and you're a cat
you're all just degenerate creatures of
darkness some type is like that's a good
way to describe cats yes I love cats but
they are they can be evil a little bad I
thought that was a fantastic line but it
fits within this worldview because I
think there's like a dr. claw like
character when an evil cat but no and I
think the funny is seen on a personal
level for me is the scene where bolt
here's the girl calling out like bold
help bold help bold help again and again
and again and he runs in and it turns
out it's the editor editing the film
together just replaying sitting fucking
cruel the more I think about it actually
but I guess how obsessed is and how
worried he is and what they do mean to
the scared well not only that but
anybody who has ever edited in their
life in you like I turned to you and I
was like this film nailed it
the editors just sitting there just
click click
munching his Doritos click click both
help bolt help and he just keeps
clicking this scene again again looking
for the right exact second the cut or
going through alternate takes that
living with you for a while that was it
like I just I just remember looking at
you like my god
that's just your life except they cut
out the scene where he doesn't cut out
the hours and hours of it oh no and they
cut out the scene where the editors
version of adobe premiere crashes and
then he punches a hole not that you
would never look good deleted see I wish
they care about it but yeah overall it's
a really good film um it's very funny
it's got a lot of heart it's got a lot
of character and it's got a good story
and it reminded me of rise of the
Guardians is a good film
not a great one but one that much like
rise of guardians I'm predicting may be
overlooked in the future I hope it isn't
but you know I think it's gotten to
overlook I think it deserves a shot so
it is a decent film a dad is a lot of
fun so it is on DVD go check it out
oh and one last thing a great use of 3d
so was one of the first films I had seen
them while we're like ok the 3d here
actually worked which you cannot enjoy
now because there are no 3d glasses for
it so sorry
they have 3d televisions but they suck
ok they do they do so don't get a 3d -
just why would you do that
some people like 3d some people actually
like watching your money spontaneously
combust